Pray and you will be given; Seek and you shall find;
is correct and you will be opened. For everyone who prays receives. and he who seeks finds;
and he who is right will be opened.
That sounds pretty omitimistic again. But...
Again, I think it is a description of existential reality and by that I mean ...
When I am in my clinic and I observe - and this is also the case with my students - I say ...
life is often not what people would like it to be. Then you ask, "Why?"
Forget about accident and catastrophes
because that is pretty clear and we are not going to talk about that. Although, to what extent you take care of your own accident
always indefinite, but I would never say that every terrible thing that happens to someone is something
what they deserve. I think that's a very dangerous one
assumption is. Especially because everyone gets sick and everyone dies.
But one of the main reasons that people don't get what they want is that they don't figure out what that is.
And the chance that you get what would be good for you,
let me say, what would actually be better than what you want, right? Because, maybe you are wrong what you want,
very likely indeed. But maybe you could get what really would be good for you.
Well, why wouldn't you do that? Because you are not trying.
You don't think, "OK,
this is what i would like if i could have it.
And, I don't mean ...
I don't mean in a way that you manipulate the world into delivery
of products of status or something. That is not what I mean. I mean something like ...
Imagine if you would take care of yourself as you would care for someone you care about and you thought, "Okay,
I take care of this person, I would like it if everything went as well as possible for them
What should their life be like so that it was?
Well, people don't do that. They don't sit down and think, "Okay, let me figure it out!" You have a life,
it is difficult.
of course! It's so...
In three years you can have what you need.
You have to be careful with it
you can't have everything. You can have what would be good for you, but you have to figure out what that is,
and then you have to aim for it.
Well, my experience with people is that if they figure out what it is that would be good for them and they aim
then they get it. And it's weird because
it's a strange thing, it's not that simple.
Because, for example, you may formulate
an idea about what would be good for you
and then you take ten steps to that end and you see that your formulation was not entirely correct.
And then you have to reformulate your goal.
You go a bit like that while moving towards your goal.
But one big reason people fail is that they are the
never set criteria for success.
And so, because success is such a narrow line and very unlikely, the chance that you will stumble over it randomly
is zero!
And so there is a suggestion here and the suggestion is: "If you really want something,
then you can have it! "
The question then is: "What do you mean by really wanting?"
And the answer is that you re-orientate yourself in every possible way,
so that the chance that that happens is as certain as possible.
And that's an idea of ​​offering, right? It is so: you do not get everything.
Of course not.
Of course not. But maybe you can have what you need and maybe all you have to do to get it is to ask.
But asking is not,
a flurry or today's wish.
You have to be dead serious about it. You have to think: "Okay, I'm going to make an inventory of myself
and if I would live suitably in the world and set myself up like that
so that existence would justify itself - in my opinion - and I do not mean as a merciless judge,
what exactly is it that i would aim for? "
Well, one of the things that I found was that ...
To test this theory,
you could try this. This is a form of prayer - knocking - sit down on your bed one day and ask yourself:
What is - what incredibly stupid things I do regularly
to completely ruin my life? "
And if you actually ask yourself that question -
You must want to know the answer, right. Because that is what asking the question actually means.
It doesn't just mean saying the words, it means you have to decide that you want to know.
You will find out so quickly that you will be amazed.
It's like...
Jung thought about this, he thought people had two poles of consciousness.
One was the consciousness of the individual with whom we all identify with.
And the other was something he called [the Self] and the Self is the ...
You can see it as the divine within. That is a great approach.
It is the universal part of your consciousness. It is your conscience. You can see it that way.
Whatever your conscience may be. But it is something you can consult, it is like the daimon of Socrates.
Socrates said it was what made him different from the rest of Greece
was that he consulted his inner daimon, his genius.
He asked himself how it was exactly that he had to behave
and then he did that! Whatever it was! He did not try to force a solution.
he did not try to force a solution in a selfish way. He asked:
"I am going to manifest myself in the best possible way in the world, I would like that,
what would that be?"
Well, you are perfectly capable of thinking. God knows how! You are perfectly capable of ...
huge trips of imagination and dreams and fantasies. God knows how to do that.
What would happen if you consult yourself about the best possible outcome for you. Maybe you will get an answer!
That is this idea.